the greatest bomb that I've ever
experienced in my entire life happens
while on ecstasy and it was so bad wait
for it oh God I can't believe it
okay uh we're going to see my favorite
[__] DJ on the planet blondish uh
she's performing at this place called
surf Lodge in Montauk which is basically
at the end of Long Island so the the tip
tip tip the floors as possible yes yeah
exactly and uh she's killing she's
crushing the set and then
we already hit the we got they're called
Purple UPS I think they're called and
they're like an ecstasy pill like Tesla
a little bit different but the name of
it is purple UPS right
not as good as the Teslas but it was
pretty [__] fantastic and we get
going we're having fun whatever and I'm
really on some like I don't want to go
on the stage thing like I I did not care
I was like I wasn't high enough wanted
to be honest Doug definitely was already
on the stage whatever and then his uh
and then blondish's fiancee goes hey
come come say what's up to Viv blah blah
brings me on stage the thing starts
kicking in I start vibing the music
starts hitting now to the right of her
DJ setup there is
an electric drum it's a drum pad it's
got a drum pad yeah and each one of
these little pads has a different sound
and someone goes yo hit the drum pad
maybe it was like blondisha's assistant
or something a producer or something yo
yo start to hit the thing right I I'm
feeling so much embarrassment
knowing what you guys are about to see
and I blocked this out I would not have
any memory of this if Mark didn't bring
it back up I have zero memory of this
and my life would have been so much
better
I don't even know if I want to see it
it's the patrons bruh you gotta share it
I don't even know if I want to see it oh
God all right go go go go go go all
right here we go here we go
[Music]
oh God
okay we're feeling it
oh music's off
oh
look at it
I can't look
bro thank God I was on ecstasy I would
have left the party
I would have just left the party if I
wasn't absolutely
smacked at that moment also she left me
out the drive yeah
she starts looking at you I barely even
looking
what the [__] is this guy doing just
watch her no I don't want to watch it
again can we get more audio shows
scan through it and just look at her and
you scrub through it look at how
confused
bro I'm like hit the beat already oh
[__]
look at how confused the crowd it is bro
I gotta post it like I gotta post it I
gotta post this get me this video this
is [__] embarrassing to a different
level
look at her face she's kind of leaning
in trying she's trying dude
she's trying did someone add the noise
in post or is that what it was no that's
what it sounds like the real sure let's
get a little more volume let's play it
back one more time for the fans
thank God
[Music]
that's it drop it drop it I can't watch
it I'm watching I don't give a [__] I'm
[__] watching it everybody stopping
dancing they're like what the hell is
going on
go back four seconds just four seconds
watch their hands are all down and then
as soon as the music hits they're like
thank God throw them back up
so Mark was so sweet and so high too I
go I turned to Mark or somebody said
something I was like bro
I bombed on that [__] drum thing and
then Mark goes if it makes you feel any
better he's hiring he goes it makes you
feel better none of them knew that
going back to his video everyone
everybody knew that just these dumb
[__] they don't come on they don't
even know anything I don't know we
should have opened up the episode with
that video bro we should have opened up
the episode with that video thank you
God for bringing this up because this
deserves to be out there as a reminder
to me
I didn't bring up the Molly yesterday
made me think maybe we're just not gonna
discuss it so I was like you know what
we're just gonna move on leave I can't
believe I think you're going through
what they call in the industry a suicide
Monday oh God and this is when you do a
lot of cocaine or drugs on on Saturday
night and then two days later you get
really sad I was telling um uh
Charlemagne this today because we
immediately spoke about the drugs on the
Pod and I was I was like listen it is
the most fun that you're gonna have but
you ha you are taking out alone
you're taking out a loan and you have to
pay back that [__] lot and the next
two days you're paying back that loan
and if you can deal with that
you'll be good yeah if you can deal with
that without using other drugs to kind
of like set yourself back up because
your tails are just more loans right
yeah so and I just I dealt with it we
[__] played paddle we were working
out we like did things to feel pretty
good but um it was fun it was it was fun
it was worth it and as I said before I
think all cops would enjoy it all right
guys we're gonna take a break real quick
because you all know about freeze pipe
you know that it is the best way to
smoke uh certain substances that you
might want to smoke that are legal in
some states and not legal in other
states but anyway if you don't want to
burn your lungs if you want to cough up
a storm use your freeze pipe well now
they got this little guy right here you
know it goes right in there a blunt
maybe a vape pen you just you stick it
right in there 20 minutes it freezes
that's all it takes 20 minutes not even
an hour anymore 20 minutes it will give
you the much needed icy glycerin
coldness that you get with the other
products but it takes 20 minutes so no
more burning lungs no more coughing
unnecessarily nice
smooth cool sensation fills your chest
and makes you feel great so say goodbye
to harsh smoke and coughing attacks by
shopping the smoothest pipes bubblers
bongs and dab rings at the
freezepipe.com and use it called flagon
for 15 off your entire order and again
make sure you cop this the glycerin
blunt tip it's a fantastic product I'm
sure of it everything else they make is
dope this just came out 20 minutes
anyway that is the freezepipe.com and
use the code flagrant so you get your 15
off shop today and start fighting fire
with ice now let's get back to this I'm
making a beat out of that
[Music]
but thank God you also waited two days
yo how would y'all do it I actually sort
of think about that how we like create
the beat on the table like what would
you do all right go ahead start I I need
to hear the music and then well do you
want to do it with a song but there's no
music playing
the music dropped and then you were
supposed to keep the beat going after so
I got to hear the music so I can keep
the beat please don't say I'm sorry it's
the Madonna song she has yeah I'm just
gonna play her version and then when it
starts getting the Fire part I'll pop
oh God
[Music]
[Laughter]
right
now
[Applause]
you gotta just ride the beach
you should make a song out of there
actually it was crazy son you should
have done that I don't know what's
happening are you on Molly right now I
don't know what's happening every day
did not do what he did
I don't know
yeah we are gaslighting you but I I kind
of need y'all to explain to me what the
[__] is yeah the difference
[Music]
before you do that I know y'all [__]
with me
I actually felt bad about myself you
should be the best you Spanish and black
that's double written I just killed that
[__] like you saw you say this is black
and that's the best you could do this
you didn't hear that that was flame this
go hit it all right here we go
thank you
hit him with that remix
[Music]
yeah that's not on me that's on the
drama if you hit it harder yeah
you go and do it I did it right can we
acknowledge right now that I at least
didn't right he was pity Sunday
if I had the sticks out of it all right
God I feel so Vindicated right now I
feel vintage you should can you do it
yes bro yo hit the give me a give me
Mark give me everything all right ready
all right
is it at the right time yeah dude
what song is that yeah
oh no why is this guy DJing so why is
Peggy goo over here all right ready
[Music]
laughs
and hit as hard as out
it might just be a culture objectively
you were the best they did what I did
which makes me feel way better you
created Music before in your life so you
should be good at this yeah but
um
from Ontario
which is Canada
and she speaks French so it's like what
else do you want I take it back you suck
French Canadian dude he's French
Canadian guys okay what else we talking
about today boys because that was a
little bit crazy to feel like I did the
exact right thing and everybody was
hating I thought we were gonna do a
Burning Man episode where we pop some
Teslas and come in here um
um that is a good idea
[Laughter]
no pushback
who push back on that idea here's the
problem with that
it needs to be patreon because we need
to be able to play music
we need to be able to play the music
like I Just Vibe out and then pause the
music and have discussions and then play
and then pause and have discussion then
play like it needs there needs to be a
musical component if you're doing drugs
without music you are missing out on 50
of the experience
music is fantastic on drugs you know
when a DJ puts it puts a shitty song and
you're like Ugh this song sucks it you
feel that 100 times
when you're on drugs and when they put
on a great song you feel that 100 times
okay
so why would we if we're gonna do this
not so often why would we limit that
experience yeah waste it talking no
talking is great love a lot of
conversations we had some sick
conversations